je veux commencer par la situation de la
jeune aisha que vous avez évoqué je veux
dire toute mon émotion parce que ce qui
est arrivé à cette jeune fille est
absolument terrible et ignoble c'est une
jeune fille qui a été emporté par le
harcèlement qui a été emporté par une
spirale infernale qui a conduit à ce
drame je veux dire à sa famille à tous
ceux qui l'aimaient notre solidarité et
notre émotion face à cette situation
absolument tragique
je vais aussi leur dire que ce drame ne
restera pas impuni évidemment tous les
services sont mobilisés pour permettre
de punir ceux qui en sont les
responsables
bien souvent on le sait le harcèlement
commence à l'école se joue dans les
classes dans les cours de récréation
mais il ya un phénomène nouveau depuis
plusieurs années maintenant c'est qu'il
se prolonge en ligne via les réseaux
sociaux après les cours et après la
classe